die wahl hier in berlin in der
hauptstadt durften nämlich nach neuesten
recherchen auch minderjährige abstimmen
obwohl sie gar nicht wahlberechtigt sind
wie die kollegen der welt berichten
wurden mehrere jugendliche nicht nur
wahlzettel für die bundestagswahl
sondern auch für die wahl zum
abgeordnetenhaus und somit zum
volksentscheid ausgehändigt und das ist
illegal die teenager hätten nur bei der
wahl der
bezirksverordnetenversammlungen
abstimmen dürfen dafür muss man
mindestens 16 jahre alt sein für alle
anderen weil mehr sind bürger erst ab 18
jahren logischerweise
wahlberechtigt nach all dem chaos das
ist schon gab muss man sagen diese wahl
muss eigentlich jetzt endgültig überholt
werden ist zeigt sich der saustall
berlin all das was hier passiert hat
nichts mit deutschland sonst zu tun wo
gründlichkeit herrscht wo dinge
passieren wie sie passieren sollen und
es geht ja nicht nur um minderjährige
offenbar sondern es gibt auch berichte
darüber dass nicht-eu-ausländer
abstimmen durften dass es auch da
probleme gegeben hat bei der bei der bei
den verschiedenen wahlen und man muss
sagen mich erinnert das ein bisschen an
meine reporter zeit in der ost ukraine
2014 hat sich über ein referendum
berichtet habe und da habe ich jemanden
begleitete einfach zehnmal immer pro
russland abstimmen konnte damals wurden
diese abstimmung natürlich nicht
kontrolliert das waren separatisten die
damals in diesem gebiet waren und das
was hier in berlin passiert das hat mich
daran erinnert also ich finde es absolut
skandalös dass nicht mal über
konsequenzen gesprochen wird wenn eben
das einfach alles so hin ja gab ein paar
stimmen die haben nicht gezählt dann
haben minderjährige abgestimmt
vielleicht nicht eu ausländer und keiner
redet darüber was das eigentlich für
konsequenzen haben müsste ja ich finde
natürlich müsste es zumindest eine
untersuchung geben und danach die
feststellung ob es schwerwiegende
verstöße gab und ob dann eine wahl
wiederholt werden muss und wann hat das
ganze auch mit dem chaos es gab keine
stimmzettel mehr und dann gab es ja den
berlin marathon
das heißt es kam auch nichts mehr na
also immerhin das muss man doch
irgendwie einkalkulieren alleine das
nicht genügend stimmzettel gedruckt
werden konnten gedruckt wurden in berlin
in der hauptstadt deutschlands ist eine
dermaßen bankrotterklärung für alle die
zuständig waren hier für diese wahl wir
wissen ja dass es rücktritte gab aber
das alleine kann ja noch nicht alles
gewesen sein also wenn es trotz
schwerwiegende verstöße gab also ich
meine wir schicken häufig genug
wahlbeobachtern länder wo wir ja davon
ausgehen dass es regularien nicht
eingehalten werden in entwicklungsländer
in länder wo diktatoren regiert und dann
sagen wir uns zeigen mit dem finger die
wahl muss wiederholt werden das ist und
das ist unverständlich also ich glaube
wir haben ja auch einen ruf zu verlieren
mit solchen wahnsinnig keiten die dann
in berlin passiert aber ist das zufall
dass ausgerechnet immerhin trifft ja das
ist zufall absoluter zufall ich habe ja
gerade schon sauschnell wenn er
getroffen das ist natürlich kein super
dass es immer wieder hier passiert in
diesem jahr von rot rot grün regierte
stadt wohl nur chaos herrscht nichts
funktioniert wo wir alle wissen wie es
ist wenn man aus bürgeramt geht wohl
nichts geordnet ist wo einfach alles
alles chaotisch ist und deswegen ist es
kein zufall dass diese die organisatoren
da nicht mal genügend wahlzettel
gedruckt haben dass nicht genügend
kontrollen offenbar gab und dass
minderjährige und nicht eu ausländer
offenbar abstimmen konnten paul wir
schauen nach vorne blickt mal hier nach
rechts gerade um zu sehen wie die
situation in schöneberg berlin
schöneberg gerade ist in nrw des
gasometers finden ja die gespräche statt
und das sollte ja eigentlich nur mal so
ein vorsichtiges abtasten werden ist da
vielleicht doch was drin mit jamaika
gibt es vielleicht also doch noch eine
chance für armin laschet wende grüne und
union sich da näher kommen und mitten
hinein in dieses abtasten platz der
ärger und die wut über das was gelegt
wurde und über das was wir berichten
konnten ja man muss es mittlerweile
wahrscheinlich die handy alarm bombe für
jamaika nennen was dort passiert ist ein
wirklicher polit thriller der sich da
seit gestern abend ereignet hat
vielleicht müssen wir nochmal
zusammenfassend für unsere zuschauer
also gestern nachmittag konnten wir bei
bild exklusiv einzelne inhalte aus den
gesprächen vermelden was die fdp führung
an die union sich gewandt hat wie sie
sich an die union gewandt hat da ging es
vor allem darum ob die cdu steht ob sie
wirklich sondierungs fähig ist ob sie
bereit ist für dieses bündnis
gleichzeitig konnten wir berichten dass
christian lindner dort sehr viel über
wirtschafts und finanzpolitik gesprochen
hat wir konnten außerdem aus den
vorgesprächen berichten was dort bei der
union diskutiert wurde die inhalte
selbst sind kein große keine große
überraschung also dass fdp und union
sich eigentlich bei der frage was
jamaika angeht inhaltlich näher liegen
das war klar auch die tatsache dass aus
der union der hinweis kam an die der aus
der fdp der hinweis an die union kam ihr
müsst die grünen rüberziehen auch das
keine große überraschung so aufgeregt
weil das von denjenigen die es so wollen
so interpretiert wird das allein die
tatsache dass einzelne sätze rauskommen
das chaos der union zeichnet das ist das
symbolisiert und ich habe so ein
bisschen das gefühl fdp und insbesondere
grüne versuchen das jetzt massiv zu
instrumentalisieren für diese gespräche
ich glaube sie wollten am ende ohnehin
nicht mehr diese jamaika option weil sie
sehen dass sich armin laschet an sein
amt klammert sozusagen oder als
kanzlerkandidat den anspruch weitere
untermauert weil sie sehen dass es chaos
in der partei gibt aber sie brauchen
jetzt sozusagen diese klippe über diese
springen können man muss natürlich dann
zu sagen es gab vorher gespräche mit der
spd sowohl seitens der der grünen als
auch der fdp dann haben wir die
vorgespräche gesehen von grünen und fdp
mit den berühmten führers elfi die
rockband und die waren alle sehr schmale
peter essent hat nichts heraus getrunken
außer was es zu essen gab und das war
schon die sensationelle nachricht also
es ist vertraulichkeit vereinbart worden
um eben vertrauen aufzubauen sicherlich
auch ein test kammern miteinander
umgehen obwohl man ja politisch durchaus
auseinander liegt so das hat
funktioniert bei diesen dreien und dann
gibt es das erste gespräch mit der cdu
und zack wird durch gestochen das ist
richtig so war es tatsächlich bei den
anderen ist wenig raus bekommen auch da
gab es eine liegt einige liegt muss man
sagen insbesondere was finanz und
wirtschaftspolitik an gingen also
zwischen spd und fdp aber natürlich ist
bei der union momentan mehr alarm und
natürlich spielt da verschiedene kräfte
eine rolle allerdings haben in allen
parteien politiker interessen es gibt
bei der fdp solche die eine ampel wollen
andere die jamaika wollen es gibt das
gleiche bei den grünen also da ist es
nicht so einfach zu sagen wer ist jetzt
derjenige der wähler auch immer mit
informationen versorgt das muss man
tatsächlich offen halten denn es gibt
ganz ganz viele interessen und politik
ist da tatsächlich in diesen tagen einen
krimi da kommt es auf kleinigkeiten an
auf jeden satz auf vertraulichkeit auf
das was dann am ende rauskommt und wenn
wir jetzt sehen dass die süddeutsche
zeitung zum beispiel momentan titelt das
die sondierungen tatsächlich daran
scheitern könnten an dem was wir gestern
berichtet haben an der tatsache dass
überhaupt etwas rausgekommen ist und sie
interpretiert es auch so die süddeutsche
zeitung sie interpretiert ist so das ist
der fdp gelegen sein
gelegen kommt
zwischen union und fdp brennt es
lichterloh nach der berichterstattung
hierbei bild absolut das ist der titel
und das ist etwas wo man sagen muss
genauso interpretiert auch dass die fdp
auch durch die reaktionen die sie dann
gezeigt haben also wir haben berichtet
am nachmittag und wenige minuten später
hat fdp vize johannes vogel bereits
reagiert in einem tweet und hat der
union vorgeworfen ist nervt und dann hat
christian lindner so schnell diesen
tweet retweetet das ist aussah wie eine
tatsächlich muss man sagen eine aktion
auch der fdp als reaktion darauf und das
ist glaube ich etwas wo man auch worauf
man erkennen kann dass die fdp zumindest
momentan etwas sucht um begründen zu
können dass die jamaika nicht sondieren
oder nicht in koalitionsverhandlungen
reingehen und zunächst die ampel machen
und was würde das bedeuten thomas ist
würde bedeuten dass ist die letzten tage
von armin laschet als cdu vorsitzende
[Musik]